[Musique]
c'était en 1969 il ya 50 ans
un été pas comme les autres à temps les
touristes au sud niagara
cette année-là il manquerait à petit
quelques chose sans les photos souvenirs
non
à l'été 1969 les autorités décident de
fermer le robinet les chutes niagara
sont parmi les plus connus au monde
elle se divise en trois
la plus large le fer à cheval cool du
côté canadien la chute américaine et
celle du voile de la mariée
cool du côté américain ce sont ces
chutes américaines que la commission
mixte internationale et son groupe
conseil décide d'assécher en obstruant
le chenal en amont l'événement est
inédit si le spectacle d'une fille le
barrage temporaire fait presque 200
mètres de l'eau
c'est justifie ce détournement d'eau
c'est en partie un événement qui s'est
produit qu'un an plus tôt
[Musique]
au milieu des années 1950 une faille se
développe sur le belvédère qui surplombe
la chute américaine
les tentatives pour stabiliser une seule
sont infructueuses en 1954 c'est la
catastrophe
185 mille tonnes de terre et de roches
s'effondre au pied des chutes
dès lors les américains craignent que
les éboulements successifs de leur fasse
perdre leur chute
[Musique]
si plus tard pour étudier l'érosion et
l'instabilité du sol qu'un groupe
spécialisée est mise en place leur
travail ne peut se faire que si une
portion de la rivière est à sec
le 16 juin 1969 pour la première fois
les ingénieurs pose les pieds sur le lit
de la rivière
mais arpente les lieux cartographie le
site analyse des failles et le stress
qui s'y est accumulée
en parallèle on évalue la possibilité
d'enlever l'amoncellement de roches au
pied de la chute
[Musique]
après cinq mois d'études les travaux
prennent fin en novembre 1969 le barrage
dans portr est rouvert
les chutes américaines retrouvent leur
bruine et leur bru
dans leur rapport les ingénieurs conclut
qu'il n'est pas souhaitable de se lancer
dans des grands travaux d'ingénierie
pour stabiliser le sol plutôt laisser la
nature suivre son cours
aujourd'hui cinquante ans plus tard on
planifie asséché à nouveau les chutes du
côté américain
cette fois pour remplacer deux ponts
centenaires qui enjambe la rivière
niagara